bonsoir à tous est ce que vous entendez
bien ok c'est bon j'ai entendu merci à
tous d'être là ce soir je vais peut-être
me présenter de manière un peu plus un
spécifique pour celles et ceux qui me
connaissent pas donc je m'appelle
françois thorel je fais principalement
des chroniques cinéma sur le web sous le
mont du phosphore de films et le concept
en fait c'est de déterrer des films et
des sujets qui ne sont pas forcément
dans l'actualité mais qui à mon sens
méritent qu'on les remette en lumière
donc le cinéma je pratique et si les
masses qui me fascine c'est que c'est un
désert voir l'art le plus dépendant de
t2 de la technologie et des évolutions
de la technologie et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui par rapport au sujet de
ce soir j'ai envie de vous parler des
mythes de la rupture technologique au
cinéma ça va faire sans quelques
instants j'espère en fait aujourd'hui le
monde est en voie de complexification
c'est une complexification qui
s'accélère notamment à travers ce ce que
beaucoup ont appelé la révolution
numérique et c'est une évolution
vraiment qu'on voit un niveau très
individuelle au niveau de nos
interactions sociales notamment à
travers les technologies numériques
mobiles les smartphones les tablettes
les ordinateurs portables qui
reconfigurent vraiment notre manière de
gérer nos interactions sociales
ça se voit notamment au niveau de la
distinction traditionnelle qui existait
entre la sphère publique et la sphère
privée
c'est une distinction qui a plus ou
moins volé en éclats à travers tout ça
puisque par exemple dans le domaine de
la sphère publique
on passe notre temps à reconstruire des
micro espaces privés à travers nos
smartphones à travers de manière
d'inviter notre intimité dans la sphère
publique et dans le contexte delà de la
sphère privée
on passe notre temps à finalement nous
projeter dans la sphère publique à
travers notamment entre autres usages
des réseaux sociaux
donc tout ça se reconfigure nos
interactions sociales
mais ça reconfigurer austin autre
manière de vivre l'information le flux
d'informations et notre accès au contenu
qu'ils soient donc d'information ou les
contenus culturels
donc le film est le problème avec la
conteuse un complexe et une
complexification sait que c'est
compliqué et on est plutôt généralement
un petit peu paumé face à la vitesse de
ces évolutions et c'est bien normal et
une solution qui est pas forcément très
approprié mais c'est une solution
solution quand même c'est le fait de
vouloir simplifier tout ça c'est le fait
de vouloir retrouver des repères et une
manière de faire ça qui a qu'on a pu
beaucoup constaté dans les années 2000
ces deux en fait créer des raccourcis
penser des espèces de schémas fondée sur
un mode de pensée qui est duale la
réalité c'est ça ou c'est ça mais pas de
juste milieu un certain manichéisme et
c'est ce qui nous conduit en fait à
créer certains mythes qui donc sont pas
forcément approprié qui font plutôt
abstraction des nuances de la réalité et
ses mythes
ce qui me fascine avec le cinéma c'est
qu'on peut particulièrement les observer
dans ce contexte là et concernant cinéma
notamment par rapport au régime
numérique
on va dire l'ère du numérique il ya deux
mythes principaux qui entoure le cinéma
le premier mythe c'est celui de la mort
du cinéma et le deuxième c'est celui du
nouveau cinéma le cinéma du futur qui se
poserait donc en contradiction avec un
hypothétique cinéma du passé
alors bien sûr il existe une forme de
rupture concernant l'important dans le
cinéma mais c'est plus une rupture
technologique qu'on constate au niveau
de l'industrie elle même
par exemple au niveau des dernières
années on a pu voir que beaucoup
d'exploitants de salles ont remplacé
progressivement leurs équipements de
diffusion analogique donc la bobine par
des équipements diffusion numérique et
c'est un changement qui a pris une
ampleur énorme c'est ce qu'on appelle
les technologies de
technologie de quel est le truc quel est
le mot de rupture c'est le thème de la
soirée c'est normal c'est le mot qui
m'échappe
ça fait sens juste qu'on me paie les
technologies de rupture c'est la
technologie qui remplace sur le marché
massivement une technologie présidente
donc assez voilà y'a pas de soucis il ya
une rupture mais le mythe de la rupture
dont je parle un peu plus tôt le
constater au niveau de nous des
spectateurs dans notre manière d'aborder
le cinéma le premier ministre dont j'ai
parlé c'est le mythe de de la mort du
cinéma notamment on a pu constater au
niveau de l'ère numérique on va dire
depuis la fin des années 90 ce mythe
c'est à dire que bon le téléchargement
c'est pas bien à bien c'est la version
officielle de faire le téléchargement va
tuer le cinéma les gens vont commencer à
regarder les films dans la sphère du
privé des jeunes qui sortent notamment
donc deux circuits traditionnels les
salles et qu'on va délaisser et c'est un
discours ce discours de la mort du
cinéma qui existe depuis en fait les
débuts du cinéma même on a pu le
constater à différents différentes
périodes dans la période des années même
50 60
avec l'arrivée de la télévision la
risation de télévision dans les foyers
il y eut encore ce ce débat est ce que
la télévision va tuer le cinéma
donc il s'est posé de manière renouvelée
ce débat avec l'arrivée du numérique le
téléchargement donc mais aussi des
systèmes de home cinéma qui se
perfectionnent et aujourd'hui beaucoup
de gens sont encore convaincus que le
cinéma supporte extrêmement mal et que
les jambes ds les sables sauf que en
fait totalement faux économiquement le
cinéma en termes d'entrées et
fréquentation s'est quasiment jamais
aussi bien porté le problème car henin
c'est que ce sont de plus en plus des
normes film de plus en plus isolé de
moins en moins des normes et fiemme qui
concentre ses entrées ça c'est un autre
problème
en tout cas le mythe de l'amour du
cinéma reste un mythe et l'autre mythe
dont je voulais parler
c'est celui du cinéma du futur donc par
opposition à un hypothétique cinéma du
passé et au niveau des discours
médiatique qui ont entouré l'arrivée du
numérique principalement au cinéma dans
les années 2000 on a pu constater que
ces discours médiatique vous voulez nous
vendre un cinéma qui soit à la fois plus
immersif et ainsi max soit aussi plus
connectés grâce au numérique
la 3d est un excellent exemple de ça
qu'elle est et quel a été le discours
par rapport à la 3d dans les années 2000
c'est de dire la 3d c'est complètement
nouveau
c'est magnifique revenez dans les salles
la 3d est aussi vieille que le cinéma
lui même et a même été exploitée dans
l'histoire du cinéma massivement dans
les années 50 notamment mais aussi dans
les années 80 dans les années 80 c'est
là qu'on a pu avoir tous les films les
l'espèce de série b qui mise à leur
troisième volet sur le dimeet du
amityville 3d les dents de la mer 3 d
dans la mer 3d qui est un superbe nanar
que je vous conseille donc ça n'a
absolument rien de nouveau mais il ya eu
après le cinéma est aussi une industrie
donc bien sûr il veut vendre de la
nouveauté
ou plutôt une idée de nouveautés pour
donner envie donner un désir au
spectateur de consommer du cinéma mais
ça reste une idée la 3d est un bon
exemple de ça le numérique
de manière générale était aussi un bon
exemple de ça en terme d'immersion nous
avons dû la sueur définition d'image
dont il est cette espèce de fantasme
d'immersion ce fantasme d'interaction
avec entre le spectateur et l'oeuvre et
c'est souvent parce qu'une interaction
c'est aussi une chose qui est aussi
vieille que le cinéma lui-même de tout
le temps on organise ce fantasme de
franchir les barrières de l'oeuvre et
quand on aime quand on analyse les
publicités qui ont entouré les systèmes
numériques ou la trois dimensions dans
l'air dans les années 2000 on peut voir
cette espèce d'image du spectateur qui
franchit en fait l'écran qui entrent
dans l'oeuvre
après la question interactivité c'est un
tout autre débat mais il y avait ce
fantasme d'immersion qui n'a pu rien
nouveau et surtout ce fantasme aussi de
de connectivité grâce au numérique on a
pu voir dans les années 2000 de plus en
plus de festivals avoir recours au
numérique pour en fait exploser l'espace
temps du festival de cinéma un exemple
extrême par exemple c'est le festival my
french films tassimo avec l'accent qui
est créé par unifrance qui se lève qui
n'existe en fait que quand ligne il n'y
a pas d'espacé physique pour ce festival
chacun va récupérer les films en ligne
et les voir dans sa sphère du privé ou
organiser des séances semi privé ou
semi-public qu'apporte mais cet espace
temps du festival est donc exploser à ce
niveau là il ya d'autres initiatives de
ce genre qui en qui sont nés comme le
festival de kinotayo qui est un festival
du film japonais qui existe depuis
quelques années et dont la particularité
est de se dérouler dans plusieurs
endroits en même temps en france donc il
ya une séance qui se passe à paris qui
se passera en même temps à marseille
tous a permis grâce au dispositif de
diffusion numérique et c'est bien beau
tout ça mais qu'en est il du sentiment
d'appartenance
parce qu'à la base de cinéma c'est une
expérience collective c'est se réunir
avec des gens qu'on ne connaît pas dans
une salle sombre pour regarder quelque
chose ce qui est très bizarre en fait
quand on y pense comme comme démarche
et qu'est ce qui fait qu'on a ce
sentiment d'appartenance cc festival
j'avais la chance de traiter cette
question à travers un doctorat donc j'ai
pu aller justement enquêter sur
l'enquêté sur ces festivals et
interroger ce sentiment d'appartenance
qu'est ce qui va faire qu'un spectateur
de tels films à paris qui verra le même
film qu'un spectateur à marseille au
même moment aura la sensation de faire
partie du même lui-même de la même
expérience du même festival
et c'est quelque chose en fait qui qui
reste extrêmement important par delà
toutes les innovations et par delà
toutes les idées des nouveautés il ya
une dimension par delà le fait de se
confronter individuellement et meurt il
ya une dimension de rituel social par de
la côte est uniquement culturel et ce
rituel à la salle ya ce sentiment de
vouloir partager quelque chose et ça ça
c'est de la continuité
par delà tous ses mythes de la rupture
vraiment qui postule que ce soit en
négatif en positif
une rupture avec le passé ce qu'on
oublie un petit peu trop souvent à
travers ces rhétorique c'est la notion
de continuité et c'est sûr ça a tracé
petite présentation que j'avais envie
d'attirer votre attention ce soir
c'est que c'est important aussi de
vouloir retrouver à trouver des repères
et vouloir simplifier les choses mais
quand cette simplification se fait au
détriment de la nuance c'est
problématique
il ya des manières de simplifier les
choses sans faire abstraction des
nuances il ne faut pas oublier que en
termes de pratiques dans la pratique du
cinéma dans nos pratiques de spectateurs
la rupture totale n'existe pas en fait
l'évolution va être une reconfiguration
de l'existant et voilà parce que j'avais
à vous dire ce soir
merci à vous